let's kick off uh things with some food
news okay too late
all we do is talk about food
well they just held the annual ces
which is the consumer electronics show
and brands show off
all their latest high-tech products this
is like
disneyland for gadgets and i saw
something ross
and i had to show you okay because i
want it real bad
it's an ice cream robot no yes cena
reports
that cold snap is going to make a soft
serve
on demand basically keurig coffee pods
but with ice cream 2020 was a hard year
2021 coming through with an ice cream
robot
thank you so much i love soft serve i
used to um work at mcdonald's and i
would do
a registered drive-through and grill the
triple threat
and i i would do the soft-serve cone
thing and i can do the whole thing with
a little
on the little like the little like like
perfect little hook all i know is
mcdonald's you're a miracle
everybody knows it but that ice cream
you make is my favorite ice cream in the
world with the hot fudge and some nuts
oh my god
i know the half and half the swirl oh
anyone else
in the mood for some sweets right now
here's some good news it's girl scout
cookie season
i know just when you thought you wanted
soft serve jk i want girl scout cookies
and food and wine reports that the girl
scouts moved their entire operation
online remember they used to stay
outside the store of course i know i'd
always feel bad because i never buy any
um i'm always on a diet well you can
order on their website now uh through
the partnership with grubhub
okay welcome to the future so easy plus
they've got a brand new cookie
inspired by french toast called toast
yay
um i like the thin mints do you do those
ones i like the thin mints and to put
them in the freezer
i'm that guy yeah i eat so many of them
i call them double chin mints
first of all why only now this should
have been happening
since like the birth of www dot help me
get me some girl scout cookies i know
it's so much smarter you can just order
them online
i do buy them though when i see them on
the streets
um i do i always pony up and uh and then
yeah i always have a conversation i go
i'd love to support you but do you see
my body this doesn't just happen up
well another thing that i really love
doing ross is puzzle
big puzzler uh-huh i just started i told
you my first one
in quarantine it gave me such anxiety
but now i'm obsessed with them
i won't do a puzzle if the box is opened
why
because if i do all that work and then
there's like a missing piece at the end
it's going to send me into an insane
asylum um
i'm so close to being there already i
should get that one piece to send me
over the edge
but they're so fun and they are so
satisfying you get that last piece in
there
well it's great to do alone or with
other people
it's like it's the perfect game you know
whether you're alone or with friends and
i'm so happy that people
are puzzling more than ever right now
and uh despite the renewed puzzle
passion there are still
some pieces missing in the puzzle
industry
and that's where puzzles of color comes
in
it's a small business started by a
brother and a sister doer from
allen texas who wanted to bring better
representation
to puzzles and guess what what
they're here please welcome william
jones and erica chamber
oh my gosh hi are missing pieces
right here thank you oh
hi erica and william i
love your puzzles i love what they stand
for i love how they look
what inspired you to get on and do this
it's hard to build a business um the we
actually grew up doing puzzles
as really young kids we started doing
them in
elementary school as a winter break
thing my mom wanted to keep our minds
fresh
she wanted to make sure that you know we
were entertained
during that that week and a half off um
in between the new year
and so as we you know grew older and we
were trying to find more and more
challenging puzzles we realized that we
really weren't seeing anything that
featured
uh people of color and that was you know
there wasn't a lot of diversity in the
industry so we decided we'd
try to see if we could change that
that's so cool
i love that there's such a purpose
behind it i also love that footage too
watching how they cut the puzzles i
didn't know that's how you did it
that's so neat i also wonder how you
pick your images because they were
looking at the footage of how they cut
it yeah uh
and so the puzzles flipped upside down
and when you flip it up you can see how
beautiful
how do you pick the pictures like that
one right there
it does the art we find artists of color
uh more than social media
and like really like talking to the
artist and get their backstory getting
the story behind the actual puzzle
itself to really like
you know we want to make sure we're
telling a diverse story telling a story
for anybody to relate to or anything
anybody who sees this positive but like
yeah that's a great pose i need to just
have that in my house as art
that's great and you have done you've
done like eight puzzles all out of
erica's garage
well what's next you're taking over the
world so what do you do next with the
business
we really love our artists and so we're
trying to highlight them
in the best way possible so we're doing
a little video series
with our artists and of course always
looking for more and more art well we'd
love to feature you on the website
and continue to talk about you guys and
shine a light
on the important and beautiful thing you
are doing
and hearing as a parent that your mom
encouraged you to do puzzles growing up
like i'm the bigger puzzler and i don't
have my kids do it and i feel like i've
learned a lesson today that i need to
get my kids involved more
yeah absolutely it's a great time to
bond like that's how we
you know we're really really close
because i think a lot and in part
because of doing puzzles together for so
many years
i'm worried i take them too seriously to
let my children get involved
yeah we definitely we did have a
situation when we were younger where
one of our cousins was helping and lost
some puzzle pieces oh you know
it was it was disaster yeah
well i'm that guy he was like
seriously um so go to our website at the
drewberrymartial.com
where we're going to feature all these
puzzles how to send an art where to buy
it erica and william thank you so much
for being on our show and help
illuminating
this gorgeous business of
puzzlesofcolor.com
and thank you for being on the show
today
[Music]
you